I hope by this point you're starting to
see the power of jQuery's DOM methods.
Up to now you've selected elements and
learned about the data inside HTML tags.
But what about the data held between
tags, can you grab that with jQuery too?
Yep.
The two best options for
finding all of the data between
tags are .html() and .text().
I'll open up the Udacity homepage and
demonstrate the difference between them.
Feel free to follow along with me.
I started by selecting this element,
with the ID of flyup-homepage,
you can see that it has
other elements inside of it.
If you run .html() in this selected
element, you'll see the HTML of
everything inside of the flyup-homepage
including all of the tags, classes,
and attributes, like so,
here's the HTML.
But if you run .text() on a selection
you'll see that jQuery has
stripped out all of the HTML tags, and
only return the text contained within.
Like so,
we can see the HTML disappeared.
But can you change the HTML and text
of a DOM element with these methods?
Let's go ahead and find out.